firstly i just want to get your reaction
after hearing the cheek executive of
piano ferries
saying that absolutely they were
obligated to consult but they didn't
choose to do that
well i was sitting five feet behind him
in that select committee room and i
couldn't believe what i was hearing for
a chief executive of a plc
and a director to state
on the verbatim record at a
parliamentary committee
they don't care about the law of the
land
and that they'd broken it and if they
needed to they would break it again is
an incredible statement for a chief
executive to make
clearly he's got to resign
but also he needs to be prosecuted and
struck off
as a director there's a fit and proper
test
fit and proper person test for directors
in this country and he clearly isn't one
he also owns the
maritime ratings pension fund 146
million pound which he's committed to
paying
and we can't trust this man to do
anything because he's prepared to break
the law flagrantly and go on the record
uh and state that he would do it again
that is entirely unacceptable but what
we also have to do
is get our people back to work
on these ferries they're doing their
jobs and stop these sackings which are
illegal he's accepted their illegal and
that must be put right straight away so
we're meeting with pno this afternoon
and we're hoping for some progress with
this we think we've got support of the
politicians
and almost everyone in parliament and we
think we can get some some laws through
as quickly as possible that will change
the situation so we can put this
injustice right
you're talking about getting laws
through as quickly as possible to put
the injustice right
but if this is a company that's already
said that it's broken the law is that
actually going to do any good
well we have to have laws that are
strong enough to sanction them properly
as as companies and individual directors
there are criminal laws about being a
director and you cannot be as the chief
executive of a plc of a high-profile
company be allowed to sit in parliament
on the record and say that you're just
going to break the law what does that
say to everyone else what did it say to
everyone else in business
in public service uh in public life in
this country where a person could just
say i don't care about the law it was
put to him if he was driving his car at
90 miles an hour would that be
acceptable and he said no but in regards
to sacking 800 people who have done
nothing wrong
where piano made us commitments 18
months ago that they would recruit and
retain british seafarers on the record
that he's allowed to just reverse that
and in reversing it flagrantly break the
law he's taking the mickey out of all of
us every hard-working person
in the country who's got a contract of
employment but also those other
businesses
and companies that honor their
commitments that honor the law and honor
the contracts of employment and the
regulations they need this to be
addressed as well there are other
shipping companies and other ferry
companies that are being undermined and
undercut by this man and he cannot get
away with it
p o say that this action um was the only
thing that they could do to make the
business viable again that without the
sackings they simply
effectively would go under and they
couldn't continue operating
do you accept that and if you do is it a
valid reason like if you if the company
believes that it's the only way to keep
running is to make these drastic
decisions well how can we believe what
they say they wrote to me a little while
ago saying that they would recruit
british seafarers and they would retain
them as their model
they took our members to work on last
thursday who were on board those ships
and brought security guards on them to
throw them off how can we trust anything
they say the economy is hopefully coming
out of this covid period many companies
up and down the country and many workers
have kept the country going and these
workers have kept our imports and
exports going and our trade lin links
for freight and for passenger services
they're just about to come into a time
where the economy is going to recover i
don't believe a word they say if i'm
honest with you
the other companies who've got exactly
the same problems are honoring their
commitments and they're going to run
their business in a proper way if this
management team can't cope with the
pressures of running a modern business
then they need to get out of the way and
get some competent people who are going
to obey the law to take their place and
that needs to happen as soon as possible
and we're going to call on the
government and all the politicians to
make sure that we have the proper
regulations and laws in place to make
sure that happens and get this company
up and running again with the
commitments to honor the law and to
honor the contracts of employment and
employ british seafarers because if we
don't do that we'll have no merchant
lady left in this country and our
imports and exports will be in the hands
of oligarchs in the far east who can do
whatever they wish in regards to british
society and british law that's not
acceptable